اتهم عقائد مجموعه فاجنر شبه العسكريه
الروسيه تامه رئيس هيئه الاركان ووزير
الدفاع الروسيين بما اسمها الخيانه
قال في تصريحه له ان رئيس الاركان ووزير
الدفاع رفض تسليم الذخيره لعناصر فاجنر
قائد المجموعه ادعى الروس من جهه اخرى الى
الضغط على الجيش لتزويد قواته بالذخيره
دعوه غير مسبوقه تعكس مدى التوتر بين
المجموعه شبه العسكريه الروسيه وهيئه
الاركان الروسيه
سيكون موضوع وقفه مع الحدث مع زميل خالد
الغرابلي اهلا بك خالد كانت هناك مؤشرات
على هذا الخلاف هل هذه التصريحات هي تطور
لهذا الخلاف بين فاجنر والجيش الروسي
فسابق كان هناك تنافس ان اردت بينر والجيش
النظامي خاصه بيننا تريد ان تقول نحن من
يحقق الانتصار على الارض خاصه في سوليدار
ورايناهم كيف كانوا يؤكدون انهم هم من
يحققون الانتصار دون غيرهم وفسر
كثير من المراقبين بانها محاوله من رئيس
مجموعه
لاثبات نجاحاته ليحصل على منصب بعد ذلك في
الحكومه هذا كان تنافس لكن ما يحدث اليوم
ليس
تنافسين اليوم يقول ان وزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان
يرتكبان ما يرق مستوى خيانه الوطن يعني هو
الوطن ووزير الدفاع ورئيس الاركان يخونان
الوطن كيف يخونان الوطن بحسب
بانهم لا يصلان الذخيره كما يجب قوات
يمنعان نقل قوات بالطائرات حتى المعاول
التي يحتاج اليها تحتاج اليها قوات لحفر
الخنادق لا يسمحان بها في هذا هذا هذه
اتهامات في غايه الخضوره التي هذه طرقه
الى حد الانقسام داخل من يقاتلون على جبهه
واحده وهذا له تداعيات خطيره ان كان على
سير المعارك على الارض يعني تخيلي جنود
يقاتلون مع بعضهم البعض لكن فئه تقول
للاخرى انتم تخونون الوطن ونحن الوطن
ندافع عن هذا الوطن ونقدم التضحيات هذا
سيكون
له تداعيات ربما على سير المعارك له
تداعيات على صوره الجيش الروسي لان
الاوكرانيين والحلفاء ينظرون الان الحلفاء
الغربيين ينظرون الان الجيش الروسي بان
هناك نوع من الانقسام داخل هذا الجيش هذا
ايضا يعطي صوره سلبيه حتى عن القياده
السياسيه الروسيه بناء غير قادره على
احتواء المشاكل للقوات التي تقاتل على
الجبهه ووصل الامر الى ان يخرج رئيس
مجموعه فاجنر برساله الى شعب الروسي تخيلي
يطالب الشعب الروسي بان يضغط على وزير
الدفاع ورئيس الاركان لكي يقدموا السلاح
لمن يدافعون عن روسيا ومصالح روسيا وهذا
شيء غير مسبوق وبالتالي سيكون له اعتقد
تداعيات خطيره تحدثت عن القياده السياسيه
من المفترض هذه المشاكل على مستوى القياده
السياسيه ظهور هذه الخلافات بشكل علني ما
الذي يعنيه
لكي نجيب اجابه دقيقه نحتاج الى معلومات
وهذه من الاسرار العسكريه نحن لا نملكها
حتى نكون امناء واضحين لكن يمكن ان نتحدث
عن فرضيات الفرضيه الاولى ان بريكوجين
مثلا يكون غير قادر على ارسال شكواه الى
بوتين هو يحتاج الى ارسال الشكوى لبوتين
لان الموضوع يتعلق بوزير الدفاع ورئيس
الاركان لابد من الوصول الى من هو اعلى من
الرجلين وهو طبعا رئيس البلاد بوتين هذه
الفرضيه حقيقه انا لا اراجحها كثيرا لماذا
لانها بريكوجين بحجم ما لديه من قوات
والحجم الدعم الذي يحصل عليه من الدوله
الروسيه وحجم ما يحققه على الارض اكيد
لديه طريقه لكي يوصل شكواه الى الرئيس
الروسي اذا هذه الفرضيه استبعد الفرضيه
الثانيه انه يكون قادر على ايصال الشكوى
لبوتين لكنه قرر عن اختيار الا يتوجه الى
بوتين ويتوجه الى الراي العام ليظهر نفسه
كبطل قومي يحمي مصالح الوط وانما هناك
اخرون
يخونون هذا الوطن هذه ايضا الفرضيه لا
راجحها كثيرا لماذا لانه يعلم ان مصدر
قوته هو بوتين والخروج بدون اللجوء الى
بوتين اولا الخروج الى العالم بهذا الشكل
هو فيه احراج للقياده السياسيه والبوتين
وسيكون هناك رده فعل ولن يفعلها الا اذا
كان مضطر لانه اذا اغضب بوتين من الممكن
ان يقضي عليه في نهايه الامر بالتالي هذه
ايضا فرضيه استبعدها خاصه عندما نرى انه
عندما يتحدث كان واضح لا يذكر الجيش
الروسي الروسي يتحدث عن الدوله الروسيه
لكن يتحدث عن اشخاص باسمائهم من الواضح
انه يحاول ان يبقي النزاع على مستوى اشخاص
ويحاول ان يوفر نوع من الضغط الشعبي على
هؤلاء الاشخاص ليس على الجيش الفرضيه
الثالثه انه يكون قد اوصل الرساله لبوتين
لكن البوتين لم يستمع اليه هذه الفرضيه ما
الذي يجعلني اراجع هذه الفرضيه هناك بعض
المؤشرات التي توحي بانه في الفتره
الاخيره كان هناك نوع من البرود في
العلاقه ربما بين بوتين ما هي هذه
المؤشرات
يعتمد في قوته في في على تجنيد السجناء
مؤخرا هناك انباء عن ان صدر قرار روسي
بعدم السماح له بتجنيد السجناء هذا يضعف
قوات فاجنر ولا اعتقد ان مثل هذا القرار
اتخذ بعيدا عن موافقه بوتين على الاطلاق
اذا اذا كان بوتين هو وافق على مثل هذا
القرار
يعلم ان بوتين يريد مثل هذا القرار الذي
يضعف قواته هذا ربما يؤدي الى نوع من عدم
الارتياح هناك انباء ايضا على انه في خطاب
بوتين الاخير لم يكن من المدعوين لم يحضر
هذا الخطاب
وبوتين عندما اهلنا القوات وشكر القوات لم
يذكر قوات بجنر بالاسم ان يتفادى ذلك
بالحديث عن كل القوات بشكل عام لكن حتى
عندما سئل بريجين هل تابعت خطاب بوتين وهل
لمحت انه لم يوجه شكر قال كنت مشغولا كنت
مشغولا من المستحيل ان يكون بريكوجين
مشغول عن خطاب بوتين لانه يفعل ما يفعله
للحصول على رضا بوتين لكي يحصل على منصب
لاحقا وهذا كله يشير الى انه في نهايه
الامر هناك نوع من البروده في العلاقه
واربما من هنا حاول ان يوصل الرساله لكن
كان قرار بوتين هو الحفاظ على مسافه معينه
منه
ابقاء على الاهتمام التركيز على الجيش
خالد انت رجعت الفرضيه الثالثه وهذا
البرود في العلاقه ما بين بوتين وقائد
مجموعه فاجنر ما تداعيات ربما هذا هذا
البرود خصوصا في هذا التوقيت الحساس في
هذا الصراع وهذا الخطاب من جهه بوتين
وايضا خطاب الرئيس بايدن كيف تتوقعون ربما
تداعيات هذه الخطوه
سيحاول دائما الحفاظ على ان لا يتخطى هذا
الخلاف حدود ما يريده بوتين لانه في
النهايه مصدر قوه الجميع هناك وبوتين
وبالتالي يجب الا يغضب بوتين لكن
السؤال ايضا الذي قد يفرض نفسه لماذا
بوتين لا يريد ربما او يريد ان يحافظ على
مسافه من بروجين حاليا اعتقد لعده اسباب
بوتين يريد الحفاظ على شكل الدوله والدوله
تحتاج الى مؤسسات والمؤسسه في روسيا
المؤسسه العسكريه هي الجيش وبالتالي لابد
من ان يحافظ على شكل اهميه منصب وزير
الدفاع ورئيس الاركان ولا يعطي فجنه ربما
اولويه عليهم هذا اولا ثانيا نقدر حتى وان
كانت تحقق بعض التقدم على الارض لكن مؤخرا
لم تحقق الكثير من التقدم وواضح حتى وان
حقق التقدم بخسائر كبيره جدا وتستخدم
فاجنر كاداه من
محل نقد من الغرب للقول ان هناك جرائم
تورته من قبل عناصر وهذه نقطه سوداء
بالنسبه للنظام الروسي الذي كان ينكر
دائما في السابق اي علاقه لكن اليوم اصبحت
حقيقه واقعه امام جميعنا لا علاقه بالدوله
الروسيه وبالتالي يريد ان يحافظ على مسافه
مسافه تحافظ على شكل الدوله ويبتعد عن
فجنر ومجنر تحصل على مكاسب بحجم ما تحققه
على الارض وبما انها مؤخرا لم تحقق ربما
ما كان يتمناه بوتين ومن هنا ربما جاء نوع
من البروده في العلاقه جزيل الشكر لك خالد
الغرابلي على هذه القراءه التحليليه شكرا